understanding the difference between
superstars and stars he said something
that really stuck with me how he
identified superstars he said listen we
all want superstars right and we know
him when we see him but what i have
noticed is that i've never not thought
someone was a superstar and then later
realized they were he said now i've had
people who came in and i thought they
were superstars and then they turned out
they weren't superstars but i've never
had the reverse happen where someone
comes in i don't think they're a
superstar and then they become one so i
took that as a key learning for myself
which is once we're bringing in high
level talent we're bringing in leaders
we're bringing in drivers if we don't
immediately think that they're a
superstar then it means that they're
probably not a fit for that role they're
able to solve problems bring solutions
to the table and implement them without
your input oftentimes what you have to
end up doing giving up the next level of
control which is control around high
level decisions you have to give people
the autonomy and the power because a
superstar wants that kind of power right
they want that kind of authority they
want that responsibility and they want
the responsibility because they want the
credit for the outcome